that's right
you remember that man and life can get
really good for a long time
[Music]
you look real sharp a real
ceo the thing that's running through my
mind
most this morning is how humbled i
am to be associated with these two how
humbled i am that you guys are here this
morning
i think we are on the verge of
fundamentally shifting the entire
industry
not because of what resi does for the
consumer and the restaurateur
but for where it has taken the mark for
everybody within the ecosystem
i'm convinced after today's presentation
that many in this room and many
acquaintances
and friends of people in this room will
go back and look at all forms of their
technology
or execution and strive for a higher
plane
you know everything i've done in the
wine business and the advertising world
we've made a nice impact but the thing
that has made me most exciting
is that we've impacted others to take
the bar higher
no question there's nothing that i'm
associated with
that is raising the collective in the
entire space
more than what the rezzy team is doing
for this industry
it's really nice vlog listen to me you
have one
at bat this crisp clean beautiful
[ __ ] day
just we just got we just got positive
vibes me and drock here
and it's interesting i literally threw
that positive vibe of this little chilly
walk to the car
fundamentally know that my days are
going to be better now just because of
that positive reinforcement
it's so weird for me how much i hate to
be thought of
as a motivational speaker it's also so
weird for me
how obvious it is that optimism and
kindness
are foundational pieces to a happy
executable
life career winning
please just cut out the cancer
negativity please
cut out complaining please cut out
negative
and inject positive cut out negative
people
cut out negative thoughts go see
somebody write a blog post about it
get it out of your system the negativity
get out of your system
instill positivity it's obvious out here
guys while i've got you we're getting
really
close i don't know if you can taste it i
don't know you know everybody has a
different vaynermedia right
you're in your own little sector's doing
your own things i'm telling you right
now
we're awfully close it's getting really
sticky right here meaning
we're gonna win this whole thing it's i
fundamentally believe it's over
and i've always kind of thought that but
man oh man oh man
we are very close to being the dominant
communications
agency in the north america for sure
and uh you know alan and jeff nicholson
are in singapore right now on the call
like getting very real please
please please if that is not your drop
dead belief
schedule some time with me so i can
educate you on the reality
thank you thanks everyone beth it's so
good to see you
thanks sorry to make you wait that's
right good to see you how you doing it's
so good to see you
hey gang hi hi how's everybody
everybody's morning good good good good
i like the kicks thanks yeah okay swiss
is now inspired to make cool stuff since
gary vee sold him some pairs of sneakers
[Music]
i've been thinking a lot lately about
life
to be honest and uh lately i'm sure
for especially the most hardcore will
follow me over the last couple months
i've been talking about um
um aspiring to be the uh
best entrepreneur of this generation or
the entrepreneur of this generation a
lot of it
obviously comes with business success
right but to be very frank outside of
me falling ill or the seven to ten
people i care about
the most falling ill at this point
vaynerx
the holding company of vaynermedia and
purewow and all the new stuff we're
launching
is going to be a billion dollar company
just the truth i mean it is what it
[ __ ] is
it's [ __ ] it's a wrap but um
to be in the breath of like
all these incredible entrepreneurs that
are really changing
the game um
and you know inspiring people like an
elon musk or what have you
i i think to be the best entrepreneur of
this generation you're going to have to
not only build an incredible all-time
business
and an impact in your industry or
industries like i'm
aspiring to but you also have to bring
the most value to the other
entrepreneurs that are behind you
or parallel to you or above you
i genuinely believe that um
i won't inspire that many people with
like the kind of businesses i build
it's just not me i'm not going to invent
uber or facebook or
the skim or anything you know i'm not
going to do that um
but nobody's gonna try harder to
bring more value you know to the masses
through their content through their
actions
through their one-on-one engagements
through their rant i mean i did a random
phone call
i've slid into like 50 accounts right
now on my instagram because of that cool
post i put up put it right here dude
rock
and then and then the stuff that i'm
about to do so
i really am i'm in that place right now
where my ambitions are getting greater
i'm gonna take advantage of me being in
a thoughtful
mood you know while i'm not at my most
hyped and
not my most time my normal well while
i'm not in my normal
um i just really want to
speak right to camera and make it very
perfectly clear
it's the practicality it's the dirty
stuff
that really matters you know it's the
practicality it's the putting
on the pants and doing your thing it's
the actions
that are really going to determine what
happens and so just a whole lot of
talking in the system
and i talk a lot about do your your
actions match your ambition and so
so many of you are so accustomed to
consuming my content on full hype
wrestling promo mode maybe this tone
will break through
like it doesn't matter what you say it
doesn't matter
what everybody else says it matters what
you're gonna do and just remember
you have a lot of time to do it a lot
more than you think
so go do it
good to see you good to see you thanks
for having me
so everybody please give me a huge round
of applause
for my friend garyvee
[Applause]
thanks for having me thank you it's
really hard for me to worry about
anybody in this room
when you're in the first inning when
you're in the first quarter
what happens in the first 20 years of
your life means
means nothing i think your adversity is
your
gift straight up
because what you don't realize is
happening right now in the world is the
internet
is making everything equal and the chip
on the shoulder that's forming on you
right now
the fact that you're not entitled and
you're not soft
and you can appreciate [ __ ] that's going
to play out in your 20s 30s and 40s
you don't see it now but you're going to
look at it the same way i did
when i was 9 and my mom said go yourself
by your own nintendo
i hated life now it's the best that ever
happened to me
when i was 13 and i had to work every
weekend and make two bucks an hour
bagging ice for 15 hours a day
and all my friends were partying and
hooking up and having fun and going to
parties and
i hated it now it's the best that ever
happened to me
so while everybody was looking down at
me
back then i was looking inside my own
head
and honestly every time anybody looked
down at me i registered that
and put in the column and that [ __ ]
became my
fuel and so i think you're lucky
and i know you don't but just remember
in 20 or 30 years this talk
because i think you might agree if
you're willing to put in the work
me my i want to become an author okay
just like you amazing and i have been
writing it's my passion
and i have i had applied to this
writing on yc teen and i spilled my
heart out it was just
me just bro yes they declined me
yeah so it's like that's me yeah it's
like
they're not accepting me them but it's
like
should i no but honestly guys first of
all
they didn't decline you one random
person that read your
declined you them
but it's like imagine if i trained some
stuff up if i changed me
they would have probably took me you're
wrong you're wrong listen to my face
i'm telling you right to your face
you're wrong you're valuing somebody
else's opinion
too much
you're wrong i i'm just telling i'm
this is not this is not a debate you're
wrong
do you understand you're letting one
random person
listen you do you understand how many
people would have hired me
none who's who's got instagram in here
cool go to it right now please do me a
huge favor go to instagram go to garyvee
that's my account
go 1011 posts back you'll see my report
card
i was ranked 243rd out of 254 in my
class
243 out of 254 in my class
you know why because i knew it was
for me it might not be [ __ ] for you
this is about self-awareness you have to
know who
you are but for me it was because i
didn't need it
because i wasn't tr i didn't give up
with saturn how many rings saturn had
listen to me you can't let something be
valuable more than you
you're pandering to them let them come
to you take that same essay
and post that on instagram with a photo
and see what happens
see what happens let the market decide
not some
middle management person that read your
good of course it's true and when you're
young and 13 and 15 and 9 you think you
got to change it up
because you don't know how it's played
that's why i'm here to tell you exactly
how it's played
one person read your story my dear and
that person i'm glad you asked your
questions yes me too
always remember that please please
good antonio
antonio you said you remember oh i
remember that you said
you don't get what people say that's
right
you remember that man and life can get
really good for a long time
take care
[Music]
you